si vous dites zero est ce que c'est le
nombre de césar qui a reçu gérard lanvin
ou c'est le nombre de testicules que
girard dans mon estime que les twittos
spots cède
c'est pour des moments comme ça que je
t'aime non mais j'adore voilà tu vois tu
dis tout ce que je ne peux pas dire moi
je vous dis quand même un peu quand même
tu crois qu'ils grimpent mais forte du
même club ouais c'est ça c'est reparti
voilà c'est vrai qu'on voit ça je me
suis régalé regarde l'époque elle est
déconcertante elle et elle est
affligeante la technologie a pourri le
monde pour moi je veux dire l'époque est
devenu une époque minable où les sans
couilles par le derrière leur écran
c'est de la dénonciation c'est de la
délation c'est une époque minable c'est
très difficile aujourd'hui d'imaginer un
monde heureux dans les années qui vont
venir là c'est très difficile
c'est vrai que gérard ta ta ta ta raison
là dessus c'est incroyable on aurait pu
faire mieux ouais avec tout progrès non
on a été dans le plus minable
certains concrètement à la poly dessus
ouais c'est vrai il a bien pris le
dessus tu as reçu deux césars je voulais
dire césar du meilleur acteur en 95 pour
le fils préféré de garcia et césar du
meilleur acteur dans un second rôle en
2001 pour le goût des autres ça touche
les récompenses a quand même os et dents
c'est en tout cas les prix
d'interprétation chaud que ça normal par
ce moment il ya des des réunions pour 1
mais le mot meilleurs ne me va pas du
tout donc moi je partage et je ne suis
pas d'accord pour assumer ce mot césar
du meilleur acteur pour moi ne veut rien
dire ouais c'est donc le prix
d'interprétation pourquoi pas mais en
tout cas ceux qui ont voté pour nous on
les remercie bien sûr on ne va pas dire
je m'en fous non on s'en fout pas
maintenant c'est pas ça qui donne du
boulot c'est les deux années où j'ai pas
bosser du tout dans ça c'est fou non
mais on est en france c'est compliqué
c'est de satisfaire tout le monde il ya
des gens qui vous disent il doit avoir
la tête comme ça d'autres mois à temps
il doit être trop cher elle parle à ta
place est aussi vrai voilà c'est vrai
donc on est dans cet esprit là oui je
vais bien j'ai raté vrai ce que tu dis
c'est vrai que moi je me dis à chaque
fois je me dis girard et de refuser
franchement des centaines de deux
scenarii parce que il doit avoir plein
de clients d'ita peur aussi de dire je
vais le temps que j'ai tenté le coup pas
tant que ça enfin j'en reçois pas thème
des masses avaya ya un cinéma parisien
il ya un cinéma provincial nous on fait
du cinéma provincial on est moins admis
dans l'est dans les structures ont un
peu élitiste mais on s'en sort pas mal
on vous en avait parlé de ça vous avez
dit que peut-être que vous étiez trop
populaire pour une certaine catégorie
cinéaste mais vous le revendiquez vous
n'avez jamais regretté finalement ah non
moi je vais là où je dois aller vers les
gens vers les gens
j'ai pas de souci avec ce qui m'est
arrivé cette heureuse qui m'est arrivé
je me suis forains d'origine et tout
d'un coup tu deviens
acteur de cinéma c'est assez improbable
donc le parcours était forte forme fort
heureux si tu veux parce que j'ai
toujours fait des films avec des
partenaires magnifique et des rencontres
incroyables et des aventures de vie un
sens c'est donc tout va bien mais moi je
moi je girard je trouve que c'est la
preuve qu'on peut classer populaire il
fait une série nature voilà et artus
aussi
soir
moi je l'espère être la preuve soit être
bouffé popularité je demanderai à mes
équipes que je trouvais bosnie et sa
premi s après midi mais il m'avait pas
vu encore comme ça parce que c'était vu
la balle à fort de france n'a jamais
géré balance bien sympathisé oui je vais
une barbe était bien propre mti ben moi
aussi je trouve très beau c'est à toi
moi vraiment je prends tout ce qui moi
je te lis chez open dans tout
c'est à toi de régler des choses pour un
côté bon jeu mais envoie un texto
[Rires]
les doors de c'est vrai que les 2 0
contre braga est alors gérard voir et
nous s'est passé un truc as tu as eu un
jeu les gentils que tu avais eu un petit
croche pour moi ouais voilà je veux pas
je peux pas te mentir
c'est important le dire merci si vous
dites 1977 c'est l'année où on a vu pour
la première fois gérard apparaître dans
un film avec un pantalon qui était assez
moulant cet enfant le premier cachet
d'acteurs gérard lanvin pour un film la
chevalière c'est le chevalier j'ai envie
qu'on leur envoie sa fille n'aurait pas
l'alsace
là nous on a vu pour la première fois et
bravo gérard j'ai envie de te dire ça
retoque le pantalon blanc
m
je vais
[Musique]
j'avais très envie de faire la peau
le préfet
salut
m
j'ai une anecdote sur les lutins
on était à table à la cantine et il y en
a à côté de moi je lui dis tu veux tu
bois un coup il m'a dit oui mais il
avait 50 piges au mec tu es habillée
comme ça je suis sûr à boire il boit un
verre et m'ont dit fièrement un petit
autre toit et après il était bourré
de monde vit tranquillement
on embrasse tous les lutteurs mais c'est
vraiment je sais on est premier sur les
buts en les embrassant
[Musique]
c'est pour rire revient sur le tournage
et coluche jouer sa scène et l'autre
disait il y en a marre d'attentats
aux mamans me dit c'est qui qui fait
face
c'est le mec la main il est un fait
divers le donc moi en chevalier blanc
avec le
matos et tout
je sais pas comment faire il veut pas
gênant il faut éloigner un peu fort
quand même et mec veut pas donc il m'a
dit vire le fond je suis pris dans mes
bras
un lutin avec
gilles parti dans un bois avec lui
moi je pourrais être ton père
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que c'était assez ted s était
inconnue sur ce final
drôle d'histoire
il n'était pas du tout fait pour faire
du cinéma michel non non il n'avait pas
de patientes donc maintenant mais c'est
non mais c'est vrai ouais mais il avait
même passé en vrai un mec mettez un
rideau l'idée mind toi il enlevait les
chaises parce qu'il était dans la série
mais c'est vrai que s'il est ma foi de
passion
c'est une qualité qu'il faut à quoi
j'avais proposé avec son frère mais toi
parce que tu es pas sa passion et
j'arrive j'ai un rêve que tu t'occupes
non non je m'occupe moi je m'occupe je
peux pas j'ai du mal à
nantes je fais des vannes je fais de
machin je fais un peu chez les gens sur
le plateau j'ai besoin de m'occuper de
toi le lutin en fait
mais c'est sur le tournage et un moment
il m'a porté
je m'excuse pas non je suis curieuse une
question de journaliste s'il y avait un
accessoire ou vous êtes naturel sur le
l'accessoire là car il avait des
canettes des canettes de soda tout
simplement voilà merci
d'en cerner d'un personnage qui n'est
jean est la case qui avait aussi des
dictatures comme ça
on a gardé
parce qu'on a l'air tout à fait con
quand on est
assuré mais si on t'arrête pas être
intelligent là tu peux pas te dire le
mec est intelligent
c'est à dire on voit tout de suite c'est
ça on va tous la possibilité mais c'est
sympa ça va sur la photo d'avant je
regarde bien on a un peu l'impression
que le mec derrière coluche le recul à
la tête qui fait regarde regarde
j'adore le joindre
ces chaînes on est d'accord mais moi je
respecte la personne
et on envoie ses lutins non non c'est
comme ça t'as pas tort
désolé mais
c'est vrai que là le paquet quand même
saisissons c'est bosser il ya du mou y
avait un accessoiriste non j'irai vite
et l'accessoire faisait